[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau rendez vous du 7 8
société où l'on discute des sujets qui
font l'actualité
un résultat en baisse mais qui dépasse
toutes les attentes édition 2011 du
téléthon a récolté 77 millions d'euros
dans un contexte compliqué la bande à la
pandémie de qovu 19 a obligé les
organisateurs à revoir leurs animations
le virus est toujours là alors quelle
organisation pour ce 35e téléthon on en
parlait que nos invités julie ou chez
bonsoir mon sort vous êtes coordinatrice
du secteur est désiré pour le téléthon
tout à fait et daniel taman bonsoir en
sort vous êtes président d'objectif
téléthon e manif quoi je commence avec
vous madame boucher donc on l'a dit hier
l'édition 2020 a vu les dombes et cesser
de manière générale au niveau national
10 millions de moins par rapport à
l'année 2019 j'imagine ça a été aussi
difficile dans les yvelines c'est un peu
le même constat oui alors c'est vrai que
les animations de terrain n'ont pas pu
se faire l'année dernière on a vraiment
eu beaucoup de difficulté même si
beaucoup nos organisateurs se sont
adaptés on a eu beaucoup d'annulations
est par contre on a constaté quand même
que les gens étaient au rendez vous
puisque la collecte sur le téléphone au
36 37 et le site internet nous ont
permis de maintenir les mêmes résultats
qu'en 2019 dans les yvelines est c'est à
dire que finalement les gens qui ont
l'habitude de se déplacer ont tenu à
donner comme ils disent et ça avait eu
avant transfert en fait des dons du
terrain vers la télématique qui qui a eu
lieu en 2020 et ça a vraiment été une
très belle surprise pour nous on avait
appelé aux dons en ligne et ça les gens
ont répondu à notre appel daniel tamam
vous faites partie de ceux qui
organisent les animations au niveau
local on vous avez rencontré deux
semaines avant le grand week-end l'année
dernière vous aviez duc tout revoir oui
fm on a revisité de le téléthon s'est
adapté on a fait des opérations de rue
on a vendu des gâteaux organiser notre
qui dans la ruse et -2 degrés
les gens étaient présents on a collecté
moins sur le terrain mais je confirme ce
que je lis viens de le dire il y a des
beaucoup de personnes ont fait un don
une promesse de don qui s'est
concrétisée via le la télématique et on
échange humain puisse de visio de
l'échangé humain il s'est même pas fait
au travers de serrage de main on peut
pas on s'est croisés mais mais
effectivement c'est via surtout via
internet globalement on a fait la moitié
sur le terrain avec nos opérations de
rue et puis l'autre moitié donc beaucoup
plus que les autres années via la
thématique des autres années on tourne
et je vous donner quelques chiffres
autour de 7000 euros télématique là on a
eu à peu près onze mille à magny les
hameaux en télématique
les gens se sont déplacés se sont malgré
tout mobilisé ça ça fait plaisir donc
j'imagine que vous portez tous les deux
de grands espoirs pour cette édition
2000 21 juillet ou shekels ressenti vous
avez dans les échanges avec les
différents organisateurs alors tout le
monde a envie de se retrouver c'est
vraiment à le téléthon c'est le 14
juillet en hiver les gens ont envie de
se voir de se retrouver de participer en
sang l'envi de cohésion que le téléthon
apporte aux familles où il n'y a pas eu
besoin de remobiliser non au contraire
on a eu beaucoup de nouveaux
organisateurs qui sont venus nous voir
mais qui nous ont contactés en disant
voilà j'ai jamais fait je sais pas
comment on fait mais je voudrais
participer qu'est-ce que je peux faire
donc ça a été la très belle surprise de
2021 et puis on a emmené des
organisateurs qui nous sont fidèles
comme daniel et qui se mobilisent et se
réinvente d'année en année qui nous
trouvent toujours des nouveaux des
nouveaux concepts des défis les plus
fous les uns que les autres et voilà ils
sont ça vous rassure ils ont besoin
d'eux besoin de nous recevoir et nous on
est on attend beaucoup de cette année
oui justement à manille les amours on
peut presque dire que c'est un rendez
vous incontournable
les manifs fois en plus sont généreux
vingt mille euros en 2015 près de 19
mille euros pour l'année 2018 vous
pensez qu'il sera encore au rendez vous
ce sont des chiffres sur le soir du
téléthon
vous avez vous souscrit après un
effeuillage parler vraiment des rendez
vous que vous faites
mais les gens ont envie de se voir
absolument on a besoin de ce moment
festif c'est ce qu'est ce que julie
vient de dire le 14 juillet en hiver
c'est c'est le plus beau moment festif
de l'année pour nous c'est là où tout
lémanique whaou tout le tissu associatif
quittent leur famille tous les amis tous
les voisins viennent alors nous on a mis
en place une formule qui est venu nous
voir il ya des spectacles pendant 25
heures mais
oui on a un thème si vous venez nous
voir à vous habiller cette année en
rouge et blanc c'est le thème de cette
année c'est le pays basque sud ouest
voilà il y aura pas de taureaux dans le
gymnase c'est tout ce qui entoure et ça
c'est bien le thème parce que ça
facilite la mobilisation et ça incite
chaque participant chaque enfant chaque
association à se mettre au diapason du
thème et pendant des semaines ça se
privent savoir le calendrier de l'avent
savons pas ce que le dire comme ça oui
c'est la première bougie qu'on va
pouvoir tout salué ensemble alors le
téléthon ça passe aussi par la
sensibilisation auprès des plus jeunes
depuis le mois de novembre des
chercheurs se rendent dans des
établissements scolaires dans toute la
france pour partager leur quotidien
mathieu de franck où s'est rendu au
lycée jean rostand de mantes la jolie
regarder quel est le quotidien d'un
chercheur comment obtenir un médicament
maryline moulin travaille sur une
maladie génétique rare qui touche les
muscles elle présentait sa formation et
son métier avec les élèves du lycée jean
rostand à mantes la jolie je m'intéresse
une maladie génétique qui touche le gène
de la sceller nos protéines cette
protéine est impliqué donc dans la
fonction du muscle elle intervient entre
deux organes importants dans le muscle
1h galène qui va fournir de l'énergie
est l'autre qui va dire à la cellule qui
va falloir se contracter donc moi
j'étudie le rôle de cette protéine dans
cette coordination entre l'énergie est
l'action de se contracter mais moulin
participe à 1000 chercheurs dans les
écoles organisé par l'afm téléthon
l'opération a pour but de susciter des
vocations c'est important pour nos
élèves je pense parce que ils ont pas
forcément accès dans leur entourage à
des personnes qui sont dans les
laboratoires les enseignants chercheurs
et des personnes peut être même au
centre diplômés on a pas mal d'élèves on
est anciennement en zep aussi ya donc
avec un pas mal de statuts sociaux assez
compliqué en s'appuyant sur des exemples
concrets marc les moulins étaient
également présentes pour montrer que la
recherche est accessible j'ai pas été
directement l université en me disant je
veux être chercheur à la fin pour leur
montrer que bath est possible que ya des
passerelles et qu'on peut donc même
après avoir décidé de faire des études
courtes finalement se réorienter et
aboutir jusqu'à une thèse de doctorat
c'est toujours intéressant d'en
apprendre plus
surtout que moi en fait j'ai pris la
spécialité svt donc pour justement
continuer sur cette voie parce que j'ai
des projets pour finir pour aller en
staps et en stock dont nous demande de
connaître surtout tout ce qu'il corps
humain dix établissements yvelinois ont
participé à cette nouvelle édition
avec ce format je vais au chai où le
voilà tout et les temps ce n'est pas
qu'une fête c'est un que trente heures
de célébration il est donc une finale
7 cette belle fête elle a pour finalité
de financer la recherche dans les
maladies neuromusculaires
voilà donc c'est vraiment un objectif
que les familles de malades se sont
fixés dès la constitution de
l'association il ya 60 ans et cette
année c'est le 35ème téléthon on a plein
de belles victoires a annoncé parce que
c'est vrai que tous les ans
on vous annonce des avancées etc hélas
cette année il ya plein de belles
victoires à elle vous annoncez médaille
est notamment dans les animations on
sensibilise il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants les classes sont
sensibilisation pour féliciter juste
pour rebondir et y poursuivre des dires
et julie également effectivement avant
tout c'est une opération de collecte il
ya besoin de cette collecte pour pour
qu'il y ait des avancées alors on a
sensibilisé un plot tout le monde et
tout récemment dans les écoles on a fait
un accompagnement pour parler de
solidarité notamment de la solidarité
vis-à-vis de l'autre deux vis-à-vis du
téléthon in fine air et il ya eu
l'adhésion de deux classes de cm2 ou
adhésion complète où ils vont venir le
samedi matin au gymnase ils vont faire
des activités les parents et ils ont
emmené les parents et la famille ils
vont faire plein d'activités ça s'est
vraiment bien ils ont complètement eux
et leur leurs professeurs la directrice
de l'école complètement adhéré au projet
et c'est bien pour nous c'est ça fait
chaud au coeur ça fait chaud au coeur
marcel qui peut encore trouver la fête
cette année c'est la cause de 19 les
indicateurs sont pas très bons sont des
mâles armand le gouvernement a annoncé
près de 50000 contamination quotidienne
gelé ou jusque là pour le moment on
croise les doigts oui on croisait doit
même si on sait qu'on a prévu nous
toutes les mesures sanitaires pour être
vraiment ne pas mettre en danger les
gens qui vont participer aux animations
là on a bien sensibiliser les
organisateurs au respect des consignes
sanitaires et et puis on a toujours
prévu de proposer des solutions qu'on a
dû inventer l'année dernière parce qu'on
n'avait pas l'habitude de les utiliser
les drives les systèmes a emporté les
visuels et voilà on est près des prêts
et puis non il n'y a pas de raisons je
pense que tout est réuni pour que pour
que les gens soient en sécurité qu'on
puisse faire une belle fête dans de
belles conditions il a fallu innover
encore cette année à magny les hameaux
oui si on n'innove pas et les gens ne
viennent pas oui bien sûr on va avoir
comme d'habitude des spectacles on aura
également un spectacle un petit peu
particulier comme un comme de
l'équitation un spectacle équitation
l'extérieur coloré sud-ouest pays basque
on va avoir des tournois un peu
particulier bien sûr et puis tout ce qui
va être relatifs au sud-ouest comme le
la soka tira tir à la corde
tout un tas d'activités bien évidemment
oui c'est un travail d'une année
j'imagine boire plus non non non c'est
un travail un petit travail voilà mais
qui occupe de nombreuses associations le
sens et la passion qu'ils mènent tous
ses organisateurs tous ces gens qui se
mobilisent
aurais je pense qu'en fait
c'est enfin c'est un tel une telle
énergie que comme daniel en général
quand on le fait une fois on ne peut pas
arrêter et je pense qu'on est tous tous
les bénévoles en fait on est on est
tellement chevillée au corps par la
cause en plus
voilà quand on voit les familles des
malades et les malades et l'espoir et
des victoires combat on peut plus
arrêter en fait on a besoin de cet
argent de cette collecte
s'est voilà on compte sur tous les
bénévoles pour pour nous accompagner
finalement c'est et novations vous avez
dû mettre en place pour collecter c'est
un peut-être un regain way un nouveau
souffle à la comparaison complètement ça
nous a permis de nous adapter de nous
réinventer mal à la fm c'est dans notre
adn le la résilience le combat c'est
dans notre adn d'associations peut pas
refuser la fatalité et donc les familles
ont décidé de se battre pour refuser
cette fatalité c'est on peut pas faire
autrement on s'adapte et on le voit
énormément de mobilisation on en a cité
quelques unes y aussi fort que
sartrouville coignières les
clayes-sous-bois voisins le bretonneux
saint germain en laye c'est très
difficile d'être exhaustif
donc on le rappelle le téléthon c'est
les 3 et 4 décembre prochain ce sont
trente heures de mobilisation pour
trouver des solutions thérapeutiques aux
maladies neuromusculaires pour donner ou
les seuls qu'on n'a pas souvent dès ce
soir le 36 37 il ya aussi le site dont
point telethon.fr et bien sûr vous
l'aurez compris les différentes
manifestations proposées sur cette année
sur les départements les deux
coordinations yvelinoise est et ouest
qui recense tous les rendez vous c'est
sur les réseaux sociaux moi je vous
propose qu'on se quitte sur ces mots
c'est la fin de cette société merci à
tous les deux d'être venu sur notre
plateau et nour on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau moment
d'échangé de discussion bien sûr d'ici
là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]